now it's time for seen and unseen
segments tonight I did it the wrong way
well we really expose what's going on by
the big cultural stories of the day a
Catholic college has killed its mascot
of almost a hundred years
Disney remaking a major attraction in
the name of me too and the political art
of Jim Carrey to explain it all Fox News
contributor author of the will Wilder
series Raymond Arroyo book number three
coming out soon all right all right this
is crazy now let's go to Jim Carrey now
what is it with the funny man or at
least former finally funny man
Pet Detective political cartoons and
he's like is he sitting in a room by
himself just scratching away and he
released these strange images first of
Sarah Huckabee Sanders will put it on
the screen yeah it looks like it was
written in and it's drawn in an insane
asylum or something and he wrote nasty
things here he says this is a portrait
of a so-called Christian whose only
purpose is to lie for the wicked
monstrous well he got attacked for that
naturally it's bigoted it's
anti-christian look like her and then he
released add image of Donald Trump this
week o Azhar that could winch up the
west wing oh that's that's not even
funny
something is wrong with the man out what
it something is really ready Rover with
a blue hat yeah pretty crew with it or
Jason no he says those of Jason has a
hotline monkeys behind him but we've dug
into the video archive and they found
Seinfeld talking to Jim Carrey walking
into the inner sanctum of this so-called
art watch okay this is the wound for me
and I just loved paint I love the colors
I love everything about it
yeah the girl was a machine gun I got
power now something know if it isn't in
Saint Seiya so could you know what so
said first of all I wish that his movies
got as much attention as these political
cartoons now he has inspired me Laura
yeah I took I I resumed my own political
art today Jim Carrey smokin no more and
I have another illustration to share
with you later but you know what so said
he was the comic heir to my pal Jerry
Lewis this man was so funny in its
heyday go back you know to steal
somebody's line shut up and clown that's
the biggest lad all right cross got a
Holy Cross cowboy now why is Holy Cross
such as Massachusetts spring feasts
bring filled Worcester Worcester Mass
was a Jesuit college right now it's
removing part of its logo or slow go but
it's keeping its name what are they
embarrassed about now they are the true
satyrs the Crusader with the sword they
are stripping their logo and their
mascot because it is violent and
Islamophobic no it's football but we
still do that well the chairman of the
board as well as the president of the
school issued this video watch this God
our community does not tie the crusader
name to the Crusades
we're Crusaders for social justice and
care for the underserved
we're Crusaders for making a difference
in our world this is where Crusaders for
recycling and that's what makes us
really good Crusaders for the elder why
are they running from the Crusades were
defensive war in the 11th century
two-thirds of Christianity had been
gobbled up okay they call themselves the
Crusader I'm a I object to the changing
logos to the changing history remember
the Fighting Irish they wanted to strip
the the little leprechaun away because
it was offensive to a group what group
my god Jones dying I was just gonna say
that they're gonna take our little mush
marshmallow treats on top of ours a
cereal that really big all right Disney
you are you're going to Disney nice wait
about what 35 times maybe problem what
issue okay well now I'm really upset
this attraction the pie
to the Caribbean it's been 50 years Walt
Disney had a hand in designing and
shaping it
they are stripping this you remember
this scene oh yeah it is a scene of well
this is the update go to the original
picture we go to the original where's
that it was originally a bride auction
where a group of ladies are lined up in
a red lady in red is being auctioned off
well
they've decided that this is too
controversial and it's a me-too moment
so they're updating it with this okay
this is what they're updating it's now a
pirate queen she's no longer auctioned
oh my god looks like Johnny Depp and
drag what's that so we went from we went
from a wench being auctioned off to a
pirate queen we turned her into a thief
and here she is thieving rips off the
rum supply I'm waiting for them to take
Trixie the overweight country Bear
Jamboree singer who there's I think
really they fat shamed her all these
years at least 50 years time for Trixie
to come down maybe the little hula girls
at this small world they need to come
out as well stuck on that ride it's a
small world I was stuck in there for
like 45 minutes I was like Teri Garr and
in the tutsi most she's stuck in the
bathroom I was on it's a small world
that's the connection no that's to come
back later and share with you my
Ingraham angle political art inspired by
jeremiad they're wrapping us this is
wrapping us anyone seen out of time